wow man
yeah no that's i think that like what
you just said man a lot of artists can
relate to
if they're seeing this it's like you
don't like not everyone's path is the
same
and like you can't like you know
if you if you look at who is the best
right who's been around for 10 years 15
years like you
think of kendrick cole obviously drake
drake can do everything he's an alien
mm-hmm but like those guys are like
superior mc's like you look at them as
rappers
sex right first and then like you said
like
i think a lot of artists they might put
some [ __ ] out
and if it doesn't set the world on fire
it starts to question
they start to question themselves and
then they think oh well now i gotta it's
cause i'm not doing what's popping and
it's like and it's very hard to fall in
that
trap because you got to think i know for
me personally
it was hard for me to develop a team
yeah so this is the first time in my
life
well first time in my rapping career
where i've had a
consistent team that know what the [ __ ]
they're doing right
every time else it's been like me and my
friends and that [ __ ] is
frustrating you know what i'm saying
when you in the studio with your homies
and you just
wrote this [ __ ] just wrote your life on
a whole song
and you get in the car and they put on
just like future
future you know what i'm saying or money
man and it's just like damn bro you
don't [ __ ] what i just did
yeah and it's like you ain't got no
malice towards money man then but it
started making you think like okay
should i be doing this you know what i
mean because this is what my people like
so should i be making it to confuse you
yeah so it's very important too to you
know have those people on youtube
once you become comfortable in your own
skin that [ __ ] don't faze you don't
phase you bro because
really anything in life that could be
you know that's why i tell people all
the time who go get wack-ass car
payments that they can't afford and
like yo man like wouldn't you rather
just have a normal car and it'd be paid
off
then worrying about like like be
comfortable in your own skin like
comfortable bro right
it's people's expectations bro we living
in a society where
also instant gratification society
that's all just about to go into we
living in a society where you're
supposed to be a millionaire 25
or look like or look like it right so
every girl like you broke if you can't
take them to roof chris every night
right you ain't you ain't doing it if
you can't buy the big chanel every night
when and all
actually riley this ain't real life
[ __ ] is on instagram every day
with 400
000 up the arm you're not walking around
with 400
000 every day like this is that's not
real life
but it'll make the consumer feel like
i'm not good enough because that's what
they doing
they walking around dior down every day
i think it's even worse now because
they're just normal people hitting these
edd checks oh lord bro just looking like
guys
what am i doing wrong they just went to
jail yeah the kid who rapped about it
and put a video out snitching on himself
i'm like why would you put that out he
literally snitched on himself
but he's not looking at it like that
he's looking at it from the perspective
of
this is what i have to do because this
will give me some
this will give me a post on yeah no
that's what's crazy it's like bro like
you're snitching on yourself chilling on
your show bro
yeah i'd be seeing a lot of these these
scamming scamming rappers like that that
kid from detroit tj whatever his name is
i'm like bro you be snitching on
like god bless nothing has happened to
him but like i don't know who that is
it's this kid from detroit um his whole
thing is scamming and i'm like yo man
like you're putting a spotlight on
yourself
why if you're active actively still
doing it like chill out bro